along crime daily I'm Jesse Weber a
former game show contestant turned
murderer well that's the accusation
against an Illinois man who prosecutors
say killed his wife allegedly shooting
her 14 times police and prosecutors say
that Timothy bleethnic was going through
a contentious divorce with his wife
Becky when they claim he decided to
break into her home and kill her in
February of this year belief Nick is
charged with two counts of first-degree
murder and account of home invasion
prosecution says that Becky told friends
she was scared of what the defendant
might do to her to get custody of her
kids believe Nick had the couple's Three
Sons at his home the night of the murder
and allegedly left them home alone to go
commit the crime the state also says the
defendant's search history is quite
damning it apparently includes searches
like how to make a homemade silencer
Quincy Police Department response times
using a crowbar to open doors and even
how to wash gunpowder off your hands
back in 2020 Tim bleefnik appeared on an
episode of Family Feud and when asked
what his biggest mistake was on his
wedding night his response was saying I
do that answer is now back in the
headlines as belief Nick goes to trial
take a listen to part of the opening
statements
the last minutes of Becky glyphics life
we're not spent surrounded by family
friends
the last minute Becky's wife was not
said in the war comparation of her
previous children
the last time it is
his wife
with a sentence in fear
and pain
and Terror she looked into the eyes of
her murderer her husband the defendant
but if you look at the big picture here
folks
the evidence will not show it's beyond a
reusable doubt that Tim committed this
crime they have a great Theory I'll give
that to them the theory of great emotive
is there I mean they didn't really look
at anybody else in this matter because
the motive was so abundant I guess in
their mind but when we went over
yesterday that you all agreed with is
that motive is not something that they
have to prove to you motive is not the
element of the offense and motive is not
something that you will be asked to
consider at your journey so what I asked
you before we get into this is listen to
the evidence
ask yourself what does it prove and
utilize your common sense
all right legal analyst Brian buckmeyer
and Terry Austin are here Brian will
start with you what are the strongest
arguments on both sides that I think are
going to ultimately help decide this
case it's weird Jesse but I think for
the prosecution it's the Google searches
I mean you listed off some of the worst
ones but to add on top of that
it's also the fact that these two were
separated that the ex-wife was dating
someone else and supposedly there were
Google searches on Timothy's laptop or
phone looking up the license plate of
the other lover in her driveway yeah you
don't need to prove motive but it really
helps when you're talking about ex-lover
and jealousy in terms of a crime like
this but on the other side I found it
very interesting that after Timothy was
arrested they took six pairs of his
shoes and compared to that of a
footprint just outside the window of
where the person broke in and couldn't
find a match both facts I think helped
either side pretty well so Terry I want
to talk about the Family Feud video went
absolutely viral but do you think it's
actually going to be used or ever be
used against him during a trial I don't
think it's going to ever get into the
trial because it's not really relevant
for first of all I think he was joking
it's not going to really show his motive
if he said something like oh I first
thing I want to do is kill my wife well
then I think they might say there's some
probative value and less prejudicial
value but here he's joking so I don't
think they're going to let anything like
that in but what it could do at the end
of the day is a jury pool might have
seen that video it's gone viral and so
it could very well be that in the back
of their mind they're thinking Hmm why
is he joking about not getting married
to his wife just like such an eerie
thing to say and that's obviously why
it's become such a big talking point so
we'll see if it actually does come in
well Wednesday marks an important and
sad anniversary it has been one year
since a gunman killed 19 children and
two teachers inside of a fourth grade
classroom in Uvalde Texas
the police department they are still
facing backlash for its response or
maybe lack thereof to the active shooter
situation a criminal investigation is
still ongoing hundreds of officers from
multiple agencies were at the scene that
day but the heavily armed police waited
more than an hour to go into the
classroom and kill the gunman all Uvalde
schools were closed on Wednesday for a
day of remembrance the school district
permanently closed Robb Elementary and
plans to open a new school
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we have some breaking news to
bring you right now about the Civil
dispute between the potato and laundry
families the surviving parents of Brian
and Gabby the case was back in court on
Wednesday patito's parents are suing the
laundries and their family attorney for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress they claim that the trio hid
the fact that potato was dead and
instead released misleading statements
to the public Gabby Patito and Brian
laundry set off on a cross-country road
trip in July of 2021 two months later
laundry returned home from the trip
alone and patito's body was found on the
outskirts of a Wyoming national park the
next month laundries remains were found
in a park near his Florida home with a
journal confessing to the murder
Wednesday afternoon the judge decided to
grant the petito family access to a
letter that Roberta laundry wrote to her
son Brian that was in an envelope with
Burn After Reading written on it it
apparently references things like hiding
a body and trying to Spring Brian from
prison if need be the judge said that
the letter could serve as evidence to
prove the laundry's new potato was dead
when the letter was written although the
laundry's claimed that it was written
well before the road trip Wednesday's
hearing also addressed whether the
laundry's attorney Stephen bertolino
should be included in the civil lawsuit
what they really complain about is that
the laundries did not disclose Gabby's
whereabouts that seems to be the
information that they really
um
that's really at the heart of their
complaint
but what's interesting about the
is that they don't actually allege that
the laundries ever knew Gabby's
whereabouts
as Mr melt said it's insufficient for
them to plead opinions theories legal
conclusions or argument the court does
not have to accept those as true for
purposes of deciding the motion to
dismiss
the only allegation of any substance
that the laundries knew anything is at
paragraph 20 of the Second Amendment
amended complaint and there it says it
is believed and therefore a verb that
honor about August 28 2021 Brian laundry
advised his parents Christopher and
Roberta laundry that he had murdered
Gabrielle Patito
they do not ever allege that Brian told
his parents Gabby's location or any
other details
and other than that one that one
allegation they don't allege any other
conversations with Brian they don't
allege any conversations with Mr
bertolino or some other source where
they may have learned that information
so Brian should the former family
attorney for laundry be added as a
defendant to this case because it's an
important decision yeah Jesse my answer
at least a short one is is no and for
the most part it's because as the
attorney was arguing here it's a lack of
pleading you can make assumptions you
can make conclusions you can do whatever
you want but when it comes to a legal
argument as to why someone should be a
defendant you've got to have facts and I
don't think they have it here so what's
the assumption that the family told uh
bertolino of the crime and that he
didn't tell the family or or tell the
public well that's called
attorney-client privilege you're asking
him to violate a right of the of the
laundry family he can't do that and then
I looked at the actual language what he
said hey the family hopes that you guys
find uh Gabby Patito I don't think that
is misleading or incorrect I know it's
being a little bit loyally and kind of
splitting hairs but that could apply if
he knows that Gabby Patito has passed
already or if he doesn't and so the
specificity that's needed to make this
complaint to make this argument I don't
see it there and so I don't think that
the attorney should be added Terry you
know it's interesting the laundries they
weren't in court for the hearing do they
have to be I mean could it hurt their
case that they didn't show up and if you
want to take a minute to talk a little
bit about the judge's decision regarding
the letter well the letter is coming in
so we'll see what happens we'll figure
out what the date on that letter was but
either way it's in I do think the
laundry is not being there is ultimately
going to hurt them they don't have to be
there it's expected but it's not
required the only thing they're required
to do is to answer the complaint and
they've done that this was a preliminary
hearing motions are being decided as
long as they are attorneys there it
shouldn't be a problem all they need to
do is to make sure that they answer
Discovery you do have to show up for
depositions and all of those things will
happen before the trial but you know if
a jury from a public perspective thinks
about it they already have a slightly
negative feeling about the laundries not
coming there it's not going to help that
all right big decision today we will see
what happens the decision though to
release a Nashville School Shooter's
writings is still up in the air but a
Tennessee judge will soon decide if the
victim's parents will have a say in the
matter Audrey Hale opened fire inside
the Covenant School killing three
children and three adults the Metro
Nashville Police Department denied open
records requests for writings left
behind by the shooter killed in the
event well now the National Police
Association and Tennessee Firearms
Association are suing the group say that
there could be information in the
writings that would benefit Public
Safety but opponents including the
school and many of the parents of the
students there point out that copycats
could be inspired by what this shooter
wrote down so the judge first has to
decide if parents impacted by the
shooting should be allowed to address
the court about their concerns the
attorney argued it would violate their
rights under the Tennessee Constitution
if they were barred but the opposing
party says that the parents have no
standing because no criminal charges
were filed since the suspect is dead a
decision is expected soon